if you are a trans person or an ally and
have ever wondered why jk rowling and
other transphobes uh say patently absurd
statements that are actually kind of
irrelevant to any of the actual
conversations going on such as
sex is real this
this reaction right here is exactly why
they do it and it's why the phrase sex
is real was key to jk rowling's first
big transphobic statements on twitter
before she did her big essay
because
if she says something like that first of
all it's something nobody is disagreeing
with including trans people but for
people who don't know what the actual
conversation that should be going on is
they see her say that and they think oh
god if she has to say biological sex is
real then clearly trans people think it
isn't
that's dumb trans people are dumb
that's what she wants that's why she was
such a big get for turf ideology as a
movement because so many people are
going to see these ideas expressed by
her first rather than understand the
context of the conversation and this is
the result